herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu diesem presse statement von
bundeswirtschafts- und
klimaschutzminister robert habeck anlass
ist die festsetzung der gasanlage und
nicht über liebe direkt das wort an den
minister bitteschön vielen dank sehr
geehrte damen und herren erlauben sie
mir kürzlich kurz einführen und dann
ihre fragen beantworten
deutschland hat ein geschäftsmodell
entwickelt gehabt dass in großen teilen
auf der abhängigkeit von billigen
russischen gas beruhte und damit auch
auf eine abhängigkeit eines präsidenten
der das völkerrecht missachtet dem die
liberale demokratie und ihre werte
erklärte feinde sind dieses modell ist
gescheitert und es kommt auch nicht
wieder in windeseile müssen wir uns
umstellen müssen wir die
energieversorgung aber auch die
industrielle produktion oder den umstieg
auf die erneuerbaren energien
hinbekommen
dabei müssen wir manchmal bittere
medizin zu uns nehmen das ist
unbestritten dazu gehört dass wir
unternehmen retten müssen die in
schieflagen geraten sind und das als
volkswirtschaft tragen müssen dass hier
eine umlage heute für den gasverbrauch
verkünden müssen bzw trading europe chf
liegt daran dass der russische präsident
die gaslieferungen willkürlich
unterbrochen hat als teil einer
wirtschafts politischen
auseinandersetzung die hintergründigkeit
angesprochen habe die umlage die jetzt
die gaskunden per kilowattstunde zu
bezahlen haben beträgt 2,4 cent wie seit
ich den mittag öffentlich erklärt wurde
diese umlage ist errechnet worden in den
letzten tagen und sie betrifft nur die
gasverbraucher in deutschland und sie
ist streng geprüft worden durch die bsa
also dass überschneidungen von
unternehmen die möglicherweise in
geschäfts verhältnis zueinanderstehen
unterbunden worden
diese umlage ist die gerecht möglichste
form die zusätzlich aufgelaufenen kosten
in der bevölkerung zu verteilen und zu
tragen die alternative ist nicht keine
umlage die alternative wäre der
zusammenbruch des deutschen
energiemarktes gewesen und damit weite
teile des europäischen
energiemarktes
mit der umlage sichern wir die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
die umlage sie ist zielgenau betrifft
also die gaskunden und sie ist zeitlich
begrenzt auf den ersten april 2000 24
die bundesregierung hat seit beginn des
krieges vielfältige maßnahmen ergriffen
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
hoch zu halten aber auch die notwendige
abnabelung von russischen
energieimporten massiv voran zu bringen
dazu gehört dass gasspeicher gesetzt und
die verordnung gebiet bereitstellung von
geld so das trading cup europe die
gasspeicher befüllen kann mit einigen
erfolg wie wir jetzt sehen dazu gehört
treuhand einsetzung von gazprom germania
jetzt sie für die rettung von juniper
wir wollen natürlich noch mal reinhören
war es robert habeck sagt und
entschuldigen uns für den kurzen
technischen ausfall hinter dem titel an
die kommission geschrieben hat und
gesagt hat lassen sie uns das bitte ohne
umsatzsteuer umsetzen können sollte das
nicht gelingen werden wir entsprechend
ausgleichsmechanismen schaffen
dann allerdings bleibt eine sehr
ungleiche belastung wie man ja leicht
durch kopf rechnung sich überlegen kann
die 2,4 cent auf den gasverbrauch
treffen die haushalte die verbraucher
nun die verbraucher jeweils in
unterschiedlichen lebenslagen sehr
unterschiedlich hart sie kennen die
verbrauchs die durchschnittlichen
verkaufszahlen wahrscheinlich muss man
immer sehen dass es auf anderthalb jahre
berechnet wurde aber für einige sind ein
paar hundert euro mehr über anderthalb
jahre kaum spürbar und für andere ist es
genau der tropfen mit den hohen
energiepreisen der das fast vielleicht
zum überlaufen bringt und es darf nicht
überlaufen und deswegen brauchen wir
tatsächlich an der stelle zielgerichtete
entlastung ein paar hat der
bundeskanzler angekündigt das ist eine
neuberechnung und erhöhung und
ausweitung des wohngeldes eine
umstellung hartz4 auf ein bürgergeld und
das verhindern von gas sperren im winter
darüber hinaus gibt es eine politische
diskussion die über weitere entlastungen
und landen ein weiteres entlastungspaket
geführt wird und es ist halt eine frage
des zu verteilenden volumens wenn es
natürlich ist auch die kalte progression
eine entlastung völlig klar und auch ein
ärgernis für sehr viele menschen die
frage ist bei knappen geldern wie
zielgenau ist sie und wenn ich über die
hohen energiepreise teil davon durch die
umlage rede würde ich immer dafür werben
so lange das geld knapp ist und wir
nicht alles anders machen können was wir
uns wünschen dass wir zielgenau da
ansetzen wo menschen durch hohe
energiepreise
armutsgefährdet sind oder in armut
geraten
[Musik]